lori myers was born in 1961 as the
youngest of three children after her
siblings judith and michael when lori
was just two years old on october 31st
1963 mr and mrs meyers went out for the
evening and judith 15 years old at the
time was spending the night with her
boyfriend michael was left in the care
of an older woman named mrs blankenship
on their street we don't know exactly
where lori was but i would assume that
she was also left with mrs blankenship
but given her age was probably already
in bed when michael snuck out grabbed a
knife and stuck it into judith nine
times to learn how lori's suppressed
childhood memories may have come back to
safer in the end that's a subversion of
expectations stick around to the end of
this video this video is sponsored by
audible
welcome to horror history in today's
lesson i'm analyzing an innocent teenage
girl whose biological sibling becomes
the most renowned killer ever to pick up
enough there are many versions of this
character because there are many
alternate timelines in the halloween
story most lorries represent different
scenarios branching off of halloween
night in 1978's the events of the
original halloween movie if you've seen
me cover other halloween franchise
characters you already know about the
halloween express the train map that i
use as an analogy for the halloween
timeline in this video i'll be analyzing
the original timeline where lori is
played by jamie lee curtis while she was
in her 20s there may be other videos
where we ride the halloween express down
alternate routes but for now let's take
a look at lori strode's first appearance
in the halloween franchise
[Music]
what would you do if the boogeyman
haunting your town was your brother
stalking your every move would you hide
under your cover would you run away to
parts unknown would you say
at least he doesn't talk a lot lori lost
her sister without ever really knowing
her at two years old in a way she lost
her brother too because he was deemed
mentally unfit for society and placed it
in a sanitarium it would seem that
laurie was taken to visit him at some
point i say this because she later
recalls a memory of what appears to be
michael at the sanitarium but for now
this memory is essentially buried a
couple years later in 1965 her parents
were killed in a car accident and lori
was placed in the foster care system
soon after she was adopted by the strode
family where her new father figure was a
realtor being the last remaining
survivor of a pair of tragedies outside
of her now institutionalized brother and
got the attention of the governor of
illinois who realized that she was still
young enough to maybe have a normal life
he saw to it that her name was changed
and her file was sealed so that nobody
could connect her with michael for some
time it seemed to have worked laurie has
completely forgotten about her early
life and is living as if it never
happened her foster parents don't give
her any information about her youth why
won't you ever tell me anything
i told you
i'm not your mother did these memories
fade as all early memories do or were
they repressed for her own protection we
first meet laurie strode in her teenage
years as a kind-hearted student focusing
on her grades and her work as a
babysitter more than her social life
unlike her friends she's more of an
introvert though her babysitting does
make her a lot of contacts in the hat
and feels community like the doyle's
with their son tommy and the caruthers
where she babysits a young rachel she
seems to have a connection with these
kids almost like she's so innocent that
she prefers their company to the kids
that are her own age it's tragic you
never go out
you must have a small fortune stashed
from babysitting so much guys think i'm
too smart this aspect of her character
would potentially play a role in her
survival on the morning of halloween in
1978 mr strode asked her to drop off a
key at a house that he's selling which
happens to be the meyer's house the same
house that 15 years before she would
have called her home i think his
confidence to center there on a casual
errand speaks volumes to how everybody
felt she had fully recovered she seems
as unafraid of this house as anyone in
haddonfield while in class that
afternoon lori seems bored and stares
out the window but what she finds is
more disturbing than she was probably
expecting staring back at her across the
street is a man with a white mask and a
brown car the teacher distracts her with
a question and by the time she looks
back across the street the man has
vanished lori looks confused perhaps
wondering if her imagination was playing
a halloween trick while walking home
with her friends that afternoon lori
spots the brown car again and now
driving up behind them her friends think
it's a guy from school but lori is not
so sure further ahead she sees the man
disappear behind some hedges her friend
annie investigates but he's gone before
she gets there and he believes that it's
a boy that has a crush on lorry oh lori
scared another one away
wait she's done this before upon getting
home she notices the masked man standing
in her neighbor's yard just staring at
her from behind the clothesline he
mysteriously vanishes once again we can
see she's getting pretty freaked out by
these encounters meanwhile most of the
other high schoolers in haddenfield are
freaking out over something else the
homecoming dance taking place the next
night laurie and annie discuss it on the
way to their babysitting jobs and lori
admits that she's interested in a
classmate named ben tramer but she
doesn't feel she has the courage to ask
him out and how can you blame her ben
would literally become the hottest guy
in town that evening
later that night while she is
babysitting tommy doyle annie shows up
and drops off lindsey wallace the child
that she had been babysitting if you
want to call out that across the street
there was an unspoken agreement between
the two friends so that annie could have
some alone time with her boyfriend paul
this was the last time annie was ever
seen alive there's a clear split in
priorities when it comes to lori and her
friends they're obsessed with hooking up
even if it means letting their grades
and responsibilities slip while lori
makes an effort to do everything right
she does her homework and plans out
activities for the kids she watches she
even kind of looks after her friends as
we would see later on for these reasons
when something isn't right laurie's
gonna notice it before annie or linda
might have and that might just be what
keeps her alive throughout the evening
tommy keeps asking laurie about the
boogeyman a legend told to him by his
fellow classmates to try to scare him
she dismisses his concerns though
probably having heard the same stories
when she was in elementary school after
putting the kids to bed she receives a
weird phone call from her friend linda
who was also at the wallace's across the
street what she heard on the other line
at first seemed like cries of passion
but the more she hears the more
concerned she becomes she goes to check
on the kids and they're fast asleep
which gives her time to head across the
street to see what's up no one answers
the door but she goes around back and
finds the back door left ajar she
searches the seemingly empty house but
no amount of urban legends could have
prepared her for what she would find
[Music]
some of you who are old boomers may
remember the halloween and novelizations
these were books created for fans that
couldn't get enough halloween from the
film they offer a little more background
about the characters and some additional
scenes and lore well as it turns out
with the new halloween movies out
they're back and you can experience them
on audible audible offers an incredible
selection of audiobooks across every
genre including horror you'll also
discover exclusive audible originals
from top celebrities renowned experts
and exciting new voices in audio members
get a free title every month for keeps
plus there's a great selection of free
podcasts this month i have to admit i'm
still listening to salem's lots i've
been busy okay making that scream 3
video just decimated my sleep schedule
and i was just like a vegetable i
couldn't really even listen to an
audiobook but i still did make some
progress and if i didn't have audible
then i probably would have made it no
progress so if you're busy like me it
really is perfect to try out audible
premium plus free for 30 days visit
audible.com cz's world or text easy's
worlds to 500 500. you'll find that link
written in blood on your mirror
audible.com
cz's world
in a bedroom upstairs her friend annie
is arranged under the tombstone of
judith myers soon after she comes across
the remains of linda and bob as well
stricken and emotionally shattered by
what she just found lori runs out of the
room to find her worst nightmare waiting
for her michael stabs in her direction
with a kitchen knife and in her terror
she falls over the railing onto the
stairs below she hobbles as fast as she
can to get out of the house and tries to
get help from the neighbors who probably
assume she's playing a halloween trick
and shut her out it also didn't help
that she left the door locked without
the keys and she had to chuck a flower
pot at the window to wake up tommy to
let her in
maybe it's a good thing that michael
myers chose to carve up hat and field
that night it would not have been a good
look if tommy's parents came home to
find lori locked out of the house that
she's supposed to be watching and
tommy's sleeping upstairs in a bed with
some girl on their block laurie sends
tommy back upstairs turns out the lights
and tries to contact someone to help but
finds the phone lines have been cut
panic sets in when she realizes one of
the downstairs windows has been left
open i don't think she gets enough
credit for what she does next while
pretending to plead for her life she
also stealthily arms herself with the
best weapon in the room her knitting
needle when michael nearly impales her
again after popping out from behind the
couch she takes a swing of her own
striking him in the neck with it not yet
knowing who or what her attacker is she
actually believes that this kills him
which actually makes her behavior even
more impressive i think most people
would be a mess if they believe they
just murdered someone and although she's
clearly shaken by the encounter she
keeps her head together enough to
remember her main priority protecting
tommy and lindsay to her shock and
terror michael is alive and now closing
in on that but even under this
unimaginable amount of panic she still
does everything right she orders the
kids to hide themselves in the closet as
she goes to the bedroom and opens the
patio door before taking cover in
another closet i think she does this to
make it look like she'd climbed out onto
the roof for help it's a nice idea but
it doesn't work when michael finds
laurie she showcases her resourcefulness
by poking him in the eye with a wire
hanger causing him to drop his knife i
honestly can't believe that works i mean
every time i watch it it's just like how
did she get that thing to stay straight
enough to go into his eye i mean i maybe
would have gone for one of those wooden
shades instead but what can i say it
worked out for her she retrieves tommy
and lindsay from their hiding place and
tells them to run down the block for
help good doors
she may be shy with her school crush but
she's certainly capable of becoming
authoritative when the occasion calls
for it however this puts her in a bad
position because she's caught off guard
by michael yet again he strangles her
with her bare hands and in an act of
desperation she rips off his mask i'm
not going to try to analyze this as a
strategic move by laurie because i think
it's pretty clear that this was just
instant i think a lot of horror fans
like to paint her as this rarity like
she's one of the smart ones but between
forgetting her keys leaving the knife
behind and turning her back to the guy
that's trying to slice her up this isn't
a test that she'd probably be posting up
on her fridge she's passing but not with
flying colors and not without a little
bit of luck as well and this was her
luckiest moment because when she pulled
off michael's mask a gunshot rings out
from the darkness and a man in a trench
coat who we know is dr samuel loomis
shoots michael several times knocking
him off the balcony and saving lori's
life he tells her that that was in fact
the boogeyman and she breaks down into
tears between the cuts she received from
michael and her physical and mental
exhaustion from that night's events they
actually have to take her away in the
stretcher and in the ambo she's very
adamant about not being put to sleep
after arriving at haddenfield memorial
hospital she is again adamant with the
doctor that she not be sedated what is
the reasoning for this i don't think
lori herself fully understands i think
the desire not to go to sleep is coming
from her subconscious mind earlier i
discussed how she was able to suppress
her childhood memories about what
happened to her family in the mid-1960s
this was basically done as a defense
mechanism so that she could go back to
living a semi-normal life without
constantly being reminded of those
painful memories she didn't do this on
purpose it was just her subconscious
brain trying to protect her i should
note that in real life the idea of
repressed memories or as the american
psychiatric association puts it
dissociative amnesia is not commonly
accepted as a real phenomenon but since
we're in the world of halloween and not
the real world i'm willing to look past
that so laurie didn't want to go to
sleep because those harmful memories had
to go somewhere and some part of her
realized that it was her dreams where
the truth was hidden dr mixter ignores
her request however and sedates her when
she came too she would receive some
horrifying information making her
experiences to that point seem that much
scarier
[Music]
[Applause]
lori wakes up to a hospital employee
named jimmy who fills her in on who her
mysterious attacker was she recognizes
the name in relation to the myers house
but does not understand why michael has
chosen her to hunt jimmy is kicked out
by the charge nurse who tells lori that
they're having trouble getting in
contact with her parents because the
phones are not working as the clock
creeps into the earliest part of
november lori eventually succumbs to her
exhaustion and falls asleep sure enough
she dreams of some creepy memories from
her youth including her foster mother
refusing to tell her about her past and
the strange familiar boy looking out a
window i think her brain is slowly
putting together the pieces about who
this forgotten boy is because her
experience that evening in particular
the moment where she tore off michael's
mask is slowly kicking that part of her
brain back into gear on some level she
seems terrified by this and not wanting
to dig into her past any further she
does everything she can to stay awake
eventually resulting in her just
sleeping with her eyes wide open which
concerns the medical staff eventually
laurie wakes up i'm guessing it's right
here while the nurse is investigating a
disturbance outside between that and the
cut phone lines i guess she realized
that something was up at this hospital
and that maybe she hadn't evaded the
danger quite yet she sets up a decoy in
her bed using pillows and can we just
pause for a second why is this a movie
trope i talked about this exact same
trap when i covered andy barkley from
child's play i guess the idea is that
the bad guy will come in see this lump
under the bed and then go attack that
instead of immediately going to find his
victim but what does this save you like
two seconds i mean you're better off
just not taking the time to set up the
decoy anyway this leads to her wandering
the halls in a day's states trying to
get her hands on a working phone to no
avail she collapses in a ball on the
floor and we're just forced to sit there
for 22 seconds watching her fall asleep
this goes on way too long eventually
lori gets back to her feet still in a
bit of a drugged up state and the nurse
tries to come get her and laurie turns
just in time to see michael myers stab
her in the back with a scalpel and this
is laurie's reaction she hobbles away in
the slowest chase ever lori is slowed by
her injuries and sedatives and michael
is just a slow walker that's how he is
she ends up barely and i mean barely
evading him behind a closing elevator
door some people really will do anything
to avoid using the stairs anyway lori
hides in a random car which turns out to
be jimmy's car but it won't start
because the fuel line has been cut and
he also collapses onto the horn drawing
michael's attention back to that she
does however see a possible chance to
get to safety when dr loomis pulls up
with a state marshal she tries calling
out for help but once she screams she's
not able to produce enough sound to get
their attention when i did the horror
history episode on lori's daughter jamie
lloyd i talked about how she at one
point suffered a condition known as
selective mutism rendering her unable to
speak as it turns out this condition can
be brought on by a number of factors and
genetic makeup is one of them lori's
inability to speak only lasts a few
moments but given that her brother
michael stopped speaking after his
traumatic event on halloween and her
eventual daughter jaime lost her voice
for a year under similar circumstances
that could be the reason that she's not
able to call for help it also fits in
with the theme of dreams and nightmares
present in halloween 2 which i talk
about more in this episode of things you
missed lori is chased by michael again
and dr loomis eventually lets her in and
just before michael comes crashing
through the door loomis shoots him down
but at this point his ability to rise
back up and give chase is no surprise to
either of them they find shelter in an
empty operating room lumis tries handing
gloria's gun but she's hesitant to take
it
you would think in a life or death
situation like this she would want to
arm herself i mean we've already seen
that she has no problem fighting back
based on her actions earlier that night
so what's going on here this could go
back to the innocence of her character
but it may also be the realization
dawning on her that the michael myers
before her is the very same boy seen
staring out the window in her dreams her
own brother michael stabs loomis and
turns his attention to lori who comes to
her senses and shoots him in the face
temporarily blinding him while he is
hopelessly slashing up the air she sees
dr loomis opening compressed gas
canisters in the room realizing that
he's being lured away by the sound she
follows suit which makes it harder for
him to track them using the sound of
their movements after receiving the word
from loomis she runs out of the room and
down the hall when she feels the rooms
she left behind explode and knock her
off of her feet
when lori turns to look at the blaze to
her absolute horror a burning figure is
walking towards her lori doesn't even
move when she sees this almost as if
she's given up the fight if stabbing him
poking his eye out shooting him 13 times
and blowing him up was not enough to
stop him maybe michael just could not be
defeated however that would be as far as
he would go as laurie watches him
collapse face first for the final time
emergency services show up at the scene
that morning to put out the fire and
rescue her she's wheeled out of the
hospital to yet another ambulance news
crews try to speak with her but she
basically gives them the marshawn lynch
treatment and refuses to speak with the
media she asks to sit in the front
perhaps not wanting to relive any part
of the journey she had just been through
all in all lori strode was traumatized
by that evening's events she discovered
the deaths of her three friends nearly
lost her own life witnessed the murder
of a nurse and played a part in an
explosion that all but killed two people
i'm sure any thoughts of attending that
homecoming dance were already out the
window at this point as she would
probably be spending the next 24 hours
in another hospital but she would later
discover that ben tramer the boy she was
interested in attending the dance with
had also been killed that halloween
night maybe it is because laurie has
dealt with tragedy her entire life but
she actually moves on pretty quickly
from ben traynor and ends up getting
together with a man named mr lloyd
almost immediately there's a popular fan
theory that mr lloyd is actually jimmy
because we never learn his last name he
seems interested in her and the two
share a bond and having gone through the
most terrifying night ever together but
i can neither confirm or deny that he is
mr lloyd it's only a little over a year
later that she becomes pregnant with
their child and in either late 1980 or
early 1981 she gives birth to a daughter
named jaime i think her name goes
against the whole jimmy as mr lloyd
theory because it would just be
confusing having a household consisting
of jimmy and jamie but if that is the
case it would not have been a problem
for very long because in november of
1987 lori and jaime's father get into a
fatal car accident just like laurie's
parents before her we don't know much
about those final years leading up to
laurie's death but it at least seems as
if her and jaime's father had a good
relationship with their daughter i know
you miss your parents it hasn't been
that long it's been 11 months jamie is
left with a shoebox containing photos of
her mom when she was younger and
curiously a photo of michael as well
perhaps suggesting that laurie did teach
her about her dark family history if you
want to see me speculate further about
lori and jaime's limited time together
you'll want to watch jaime's episode of
horror history which you can find by
clicking that video on the left remember
to subscribe to cz's world for new
horrors every week ring the death bell
for all notifications and i'll see you
in the next one assuming we both survive
[Music]